[Music]
so a few nights ago my girlfriend and I
had a couple drinks and convinced
ourselves that we needed to go down the
street to Bond for snacks we ended up
with a sort of weird grouping of 6 items
toasted sesame water crackers some
smoked mozzarella cheese chickpea chips
a dozen eggs because you always need
eggs just sweet young coconut because I
saw it near the cash register and
scallions because honey why do we get
scallions again ah well apparently
nobody knows why we got this guy's
anyway we enjoyed the snacks they were
all really good but then I happen to
look at the cheque and I realized that I
had accidentally paid for 17 federal
programs okay
not exactly but let me explain this year
the federal budget request for the
Corporation for Public Broadcasting the
organization that runs PBS NPR and over
1,400 locally owned public radio and
television stations is four hundred and
forty five million dollars using the
latest census information that comes out
to a dollar and 37 cents per American
per year or about the cost of 12 and a
half toasted sesame water crackers the
National Endowment for the Arts wants a
budget of only 150 million to help fund
art exhibitions and our education across
the country to help America imagine
itself artistically each of us has to
pay just this much smoked mozzarella
cheese per year you might be wondering
why I'm bringing all this up it's
because in the next few weeks you're
likely to see the Trump administration
proposed dramatic budget cuts to the
federal government that will seek to
privatize the Corporation for Public
Broadcasting and eliminate the National
Endowment of the Arts completely as well
as 15 other programs thanks to some good
work from Taylor pepper over at Time
magazine we know that taken together
these 17 programs will cost every
American 22 dollars and 36 cents per
year the exact cost of my late-night
snack run here's what though each cost
you individually and what they do cue
the montage music the National Endowment
for Humanities
helps fund museums colleges libraries
and things like Ken Burns awesome Civil
War documentary it will cost you the
price of just one cake minority business
development agency promotes the growth
of businesses owned and operated by
minority entrepreneurs it costs everyone
just 11 cents or this many chopped
scallions you can fund the economic
development administration an
organization that supplies regional and
local businesses with the infrastructure
they need to compete in the global
market for 20% of the water in this
coconut for the cost of six water
crackers with cheese you can support the
international trade administration which
helps enforce trade law for US companies
for 20% of one bag of chickpea chips
you'll fund the manufacturing extension
partnership which is dedicated to
strengthening small and medium sized
manufacturers for 17% more chickpea
chips you'll fund the office of violence
against women which oversees programs
across the country that reduced domestic
violence and sexual assaults the Legal
Services Corporation helps poor
Americans afford legal services that'll
cost you just 3 eggs fried plus some
scallions the Civil Rights Division of
the Justice Department vise
discrimination and protects voting
rights that'll cost you just a couple
shots of coconut water plus some
scallions to fund the UN
Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
Change which compiles the latest
scientific data on global warming you
have to throw in just this much of a
chickpea chip the office of electricity
deliverability and energy reliability
invests in making our energy grid more
stable and secure it costs all the
scallions the scallions are really cheap
and finally the office of energy
efficiency and renewable energy aids
efforts to transition America to a clean
energy economy it's the most expensive
of the bunch yet it only costs the price
of one box of water crackers and one bag
of chips the blueprint for these cuts
comes from a paper put out by the
Heritage Foundation a conservative think
tank that has long argued for
eliminating federal programs as a way to
reduce our twenty trillion dollar
national debt but the problem is that
altogether these programs are asking for
only 7.3 billion dollars which is 1% of
the non-defense discretionary spending
that our government does
fully half of discretionary spending
goes to the military something that the
Trump administration is not likely to
slash all that much and in total all
discretionary spending makes up only 31
percent of the federal budget the rest
goes to Social Security Medicare
Medicaid entitlements that Trump has
also vowed not to touch
in other words privatizing or
eliminating these 17 programs is really
only a symbolic gesture that won't do
much of anything the good news is that
this is a fight that should be pretty
easy to win if you're willing to spend
drunkenly or not 22 dollars and 36 cents
on these 17 programs call your
Congressman and say so and if they want
to know why you think privatizing PBS or
killing the National Endowment of the
Arts is a bunch of [ __ ] feel free to
send them this video
[Music]
playing everybody thanks for watching
nerdfighter t-shirt still available at
dftba calm send me a picture if you've
got one anyway thanks the crunchyroll
for sponsoring this episode if you don't
know crunchyroll is like the Netflix of
anime it's really cool it's got
thousands of titles all HD and if
something air is in Japan it's going to
be on crunchyroll an hour later so you
can see the latest stuff ways animes
stuff coming out of Japan on crunchyroll
I want to recommend Cowboy Bebop
which is in my opinion a work of art and
if you find out that crunchyroll.com
collection nerdwriter
you get a free 30-day trial which would
allow you to watch that show and I think
that you would really like it anyway
I'll see you guys next Wednesday and
thanks again for watching